[موسيقى]
أربعة آلاف كيلومتر على أربع عجلات صغيرة من
أجل توم دروري الأسترالي ،
لقد كانت رحلة مدتها أربعة أشهر ذات
أبعاد قارية وكلها كانت تعتمد على
أصغر وسيلة نقل
على لوح تزلج عندما كان كورونا يحدث كما حدث
في الوباء الذي كان يحدث.
حصلت على القليل من البوصة والقدمين قليلاً من
حمى المقصورة في المنزل
، ولذا بدأت في التزلج مثل
مسافات أطول فقط
لتصفية رأسي قليلاً ، لذا أعني أنني
لا أعرف أنني كنت أبحث فقط عن
مغامرة ، مرحبًا
بمغامرة  كن بخير
[موسيقى]
شرع البالغ من العمر 28 عامًا في رحلة ملحمية
لاكتشاف الذات من
ملبورن إلى كيرنز
وعلى طول الطريق اكتسب منظورًا فريدًا
للساحل الشرقي لبلده ،
هناك ثعبان ضخم تم أكله للتو
لقد كان الأمر مثيرًا وملهمًا ولكنه
مرهق أيضًا في
بعض الأحيان حيث كان يغطي حوالي 100 كيلومتر
في يوم واحد ،
فقد واجه ثعابين مميتة
وحركة مرور خطيرة والحرارة الشديدة في
سوم الصيف الأسترالي  كانت الأيام ببساطة قاسية ، كانت 38
درجة طوال اليوم
ولم يكن هناك توقف بينهما ولا
حتى من أجل الماء ، لذا كان علي أن أحمل
كل المياه معي ، فقد كان الجو جافًا
وكانت الشمس تمامًا مثل الصراخ في وجهي
وكان
نصف النهائي ذاهبًا  طوال اليوم والطريق كان خشنًا للغاية ،
كان جسدي
يهتز بشدة مثل كل
يوم وأتذكر العودة إلى منتصف
الطريق وكان هناك كما لو كنت
أتسابق فقط كنت بحاجة إلى العثور على ظلال وكان ذلك
لأنني كنت أفكر
أنني لا أفعل  لا أحصل على الظل كما لو أنني سأواجه
مشكلة هنا وأنا في الخارج في
منتصف اللامكان بمفردي ،
لذا توم ، كيف حال اللوح ،
أحصل على بعض العجلات الجديدة التي أنا على وشك
تغييرها الآن هذه هي لوحي
لقد كنت هنا أجمع الملصقات في كل مكان
أذهب إليه ، وهو أمر رائع جدًا
، لقد مر توم بستة أزواج من
الأحذية وأربع مجموعات من العجلات ، وكانت
التجربة بأكملها بعيدة كل البعد عن
طرق بلدته الصغيرة حيث عمل من
بين أشياء أخرى
تحت الأرض كعامل
منجم  يقول الرحلة الملحمية حيث أصبح
صديقًا  الغرباء على طول الطريق
قد غيروه إلى الأبد ، لقد تغيرت صحتي العقلية إلى الأبد
، لم تكن أبدًا أفضل من أي وقت مضى
منذ أن بدأت هذه الرحلة ،
أشعر بالوضوح الشديد وأشعر بأنني على
اتصال أكثر بالطبيعة وأيضًا على اتصال
بالناس  بشكل عام ، أعتقد أننا جميعًا نكبر
ونصبح متأصلًا فينا لدرجة أننا
لا ينبغي أن نثق في الناس ،
ويكاد الأمر يشبه أننا نعيش في خوف
أيضًا ليس فقط للناس ولكن من
العناصر
ومنذ أن بدأت  أخبرني الجميع في هذه الرحلة
بكل الأشياء السيئة التي يمكن أن
تسوء ،
أي شيء أريد أن أفعله الآن في
حياتي الآن إذا قلت يومًا أنه صعب جدًا أو
أي شيء سأكون مثله جيدًا ، لقد
تزلجت من ملبورن لأتمكن من ذلك
إذا كان بإمكاني القيام بذلك  أنه يمكنني بالتأكيد القيام
بذلك ،
فهو أيضًا يحقق أحلامًا أخرى من
خلال جمع الأموال على طول الطريق التي
ستحصل بها دولة لاو الآن على أول حديقة تزلج على الإطلاق ،
يقول توم إنه مستعد للعودة إلى المنزل والعثور
على وظيفة لن يفعل شيئًا كهذا
مرة أخرى
لكنه صنع ذكريات كافية تدوم مدى
الحياة  ime don riddell
[موسيقى]
cnn